السلام عليكم انا عليه راشد عفس عمري 14
سنه شو
اخباركم انا بعد بخير وماما بعد
بخير انا احب ماماه وايد واكيد كلكم تحبون
امهاتكم واكيد بعد تسوون اشياء تخليهم
يعصبون يتضايقون بس بعد تحبونهم وانا بعد
نفسكم بس بعد احب
اسوا شيء يوم تقولنا انا واختي اليوم
بنطلع وتكون الساعه 12 ونص وتقولنا عه ونص
ابيكم ياسين انتوا الاثنتين بع بيكم في
الصاله تنش ماما عه ونص تشوفنا انا واختي
في الحجره ندور وندور وندور وندور ماما
يلا ي عليه يلا يعاش يلا ي عليه يلا يعاش
واحنا ندور وندور وندور اكيد كلكم تسالون
هاي شو تدور هالكثر انا بروحي ما ب عارفه
شو ادور عارفه شو البس حق المكان اللي
بسير له الكبد قدامي والثياب كلها قدامي
ولا ابدل والبس مره ثاني وابدل والبس مره
ثانيه والحجره تستوي لايث وما ما تعصب
زياده فانا فكرت قلت ليش البس هها البدله
حق هال المناسبه وليش البس هاللبس حق
هالمكان تميت افكر في كل الاشياء بروحي
وقلت ليش ما يكون عند كل وحده
فينا الديزاينر الخاص فيها ساره
سار وراها سارت منه سار وراها واي شي تبه
يسويلها اياه الحين انا بتخيل الديزاينر
واقف حذال يقوللي البسي هذا زين عليك لا
لا هذا مو بشي هذا هذا يناسبك تخيلو هشي
يستوي في الصدق صراحه لو هشي كان موجود
انا وايد
بستانس لو كان هشي موجود انا ابغي
الديزاينر مالي يكون في جيبي وشوفي جيوبكم
تلفوناتكم وشوف ه التلفونات
اب ومن هال الابس اب فاشن ميلون اللي هو
انا فكرت فيه واتوقع بيساعد كل بنت تعاني
من نفس مشكلتي اللي هي تتاخر على المكان
اللي بتصير له بحجه انها مو ب عارفه شو
تلبس ها الاب بيطلب منكم اشياء عديده نس
مواصفاتك يعني وزنك طولك لون بشرك اشياء
تخصك عشان م يختار لبس يختار على حسب
مواصفاتك انت وبعد بيطلب منك انك تصورين
كل ثيابك اللي في الكبت ففي طريقتين يا
انك تصورينه بالطريقه الاولى اللي هي
تطلعين اللبس
وتحطينه وتصوره وتردين تلقينه وتطلعين
اللي عقبه وتصور وتاخذين وايد وقت او في
طريقه ثانيه اللي هي تصورين الكود اللي
موجود
على تصورين الكود اللي موجود على البدله
وبيطلعلك بتطلعلك الصوره على طول في
التليفون على اساس ان احنا بنكون متفقين
ويا المحلات ان اي لبس انت تاخذينه يكون
وياه كود وتطلع الصوره على طول في التلفون
في حال اللبس اللي انا اخذته مو من
المحلات اللي اللي متفقين وياها تردين
للطريقه الاولى اللي هي تصورين وتردين
وهذا كيف يشتغل هذا
الاب وايد سهل ووايد بسيط بس تحطيه المكان
اللي بتسير لله بتسيري لله وهو على طول
بيطلع لك اللبس المناسب في ثلاث ثواني
اوكي طلعلي لبس وانا مو بعجبني هاللبس
اللي طلع شو اسوي ادق هاي العلامه ويبد لي
اللبس لين ما يعيبني اللبس اللي انا ابه
في وايد مميزات في هذا الاب من هاي
المميزات ميزه
الغسيل انا رديت الحين من الطلعه ولبسي
خايس بعق في الغسيل هذا الاب كيف يعرف ان
هذا لبس في الغسيل ما يختار لي هذا اللبس
مره ثانيه هاي العلامه بتطلع على هاي
العلامه بتطلع على
ال هاي العلامه بتطلع على هاي العلامه
بتطلع اسف هاي العلامه بتطلع على اللبس
انه ما يختارلك مره ثانيه يعني كيف تلبسين
بدله مبلوله ما يستوي وفي بعد ميزه ثانيه
اللي هي ميزه الفيفورت انا عندي بنطلون
وايد احبه ووايد ارتاح يوم
البسه فاحه في قائمه الفيفورت وهو يختار
لياه باستمرار وفي بعد في بعد خاصيه اللي
هي الشوبنج اي بنت طبيعيه بتشل اللبس
وبتصير غرفه القياس بت قايسه اطلع عود
عليها بترد مكان ب تتاخذ اصغر لين ما
يناسبها اللبس هذا الاب بيساعدك وايد
وبيخلي عمليه التسوق عندك اسرع فمجرد انك
تصورين اللبس اللي انت تبينه ويطلعلك
بيكون عليك في الاب ماله داعي يعني تسيرين
غرفه القياس وتقاسي بيطلعلك اياه كيف
كيكون على اساس ان عنده مواصفاتك اصلا في
التلفون الشباب اللي هني يقولون احنا شو
وضعنا هني هي مو بياس تكلمنا ابدا ان شاء
الله اذا طبقت هاي الفكره بيكون حتى في
تحديث حقكم انتم وحق الاطفال وكل حد ان
شاء الله
بيستخدمه اتمنى ان هذا الشي يستوي في
الصدق او هاي الفكره تطبق لان اذا طرحت
هاي الفكره قبل 20 او 30 سنه ممكن تكون
حلم ويتبخر لكن الحين احنا في عصر
التكنولوجيا ممكن تتحقق هاي الفكره وتستوي
في الصدق
وصراحه انا برتاح وكلكم بترتاحو امهاتنا
بعد بيرتاحوا وما بيعصب علينا مره ثانيه
شكرا